it is not easy to stay optimistic in the
middle of a worldwide pandemic but the
Dalai Lama says there are still many
reasons to be thankful the spiritual
leader of Tibet's Buddhist is doing a
lot less traveling these days because of
kovat 19 concerns and his age ramie
Inocencio spoke with the Dalai Lama this
morning so Ramey what did you learn it's
always interesting to hear what the
Dalai Lama has to say well the word gale
obviously is enlightening every time you
speak to the Dalai Lama this was my
first time very excited to speak with
him for 90 minutes total we distilled
this all down for you this morning but
you know he is safe and isolated from
coronavirus in northern India at his
residence there but technology
definitely shortened that distance
between here and Tokyo there in Tokyo
rather but we talked about compassion we
talked about a racism in the United
States and we also talked about
President Trump while Buddhist followers
spin prayer wheels to accumulate good
karma using gloves for protection high
in the Himalayas of northern India the
Dalai Lama lives and prays the exiled
Tibetan spiritual leaders message of
compassion and altruism is unchanged on
the eve of his 85th birthday his
holiness stays social from a distance
what is a day in the life of the Dalai
Lama
during the corona virus pandemic not
much not much differences Buddhist
practitioner mind is more important than
physical isolation is not new for the
Dalai Lama he fled Tibet in 1959 after
China invaded and annexed his country
he's lived in Dharamsala ever since but
he tells me he watches the news every
day how do you make sense of the
suffering in the world right now no in
America it's quite a narrow magic
thinking black people white people there
are same human brother sisters so
they are the basis of color and also you
see different faiths different religion
and different country now these are all
thinking how do we how do we teach
people to not be racist to not be
discriminatory I think we should
emphasis oneness sameness Elvis is dead
all these you see strong feeling of
differences deaths this is short-sighted
narrow-minded the Dalai Lama and Tibet
three million people have been sidelined
themselves by China Beijing has
imprisoned Tibetans diluted the Tibetan
language and made pictures of the Dalai
Lama himself illegal replaced with
pictures of China's President Xi Jinping
what does Washington need to do about
ensuring or supporting the future of
Tibet and its identity when he become
president
he mentioned America first
dad I find uncomfortable would you be
happy to meet President Trump if he
invited you because of my physical long
flight not easy
president Trump come to India but then
friendly speaking sometimes president
from tomorrow complicated and there you
hear the Dalai Lama with his noticeable
laughter on a lighter note also the
Dalai Lama is celebrating his 85th
birthday this July 6 in just less than
two weeks time and guess what he's
dropping his very first album it's
called inner worlds and it's a mix of
him chanting mantras along with that set
to drum and bass so it proves that you
are never too old to start something new
me innocencio until I think I love the
dalai lama's laughs that's me every time
I love him saying you know president
Trump too complicated and then he just
sort of laughs and what do you say after
that okay where do you go